alors catherine au mois de novembre donc
le châtelet avec combien de musiciens de
sur scène alors qu'elle symphony
orchestra qui se compose de 40 musiciens
et je les mets sur scène
ouais parce que j'ai toujours j'ai été
musicienne de faux orchestre et on
souffre de ça mais moi je pense que
c'est dommage de s'offrir 40 musiciens
dans une fosse venue en pleine lumière
moi je vais les mettre dans une vraie
limite sur scène ouais ça s'appelle
comment ça s'appelle sans délai
romantique c'est une évocation des
futurs jeux sur un quai alors tu sais
que les gens ne manqueront pas de jaser
sur le fait que tu t'intéresses genre
jeu semble qu'en maintenant jazz et
pourquoi pas parce que tu as déclaré
chez denisot chez michel denisot tu as
demandé quand vous regardez d'abord chez
un homme voilà et tu as répondu sa femme
ou ses excellents du mali meilleure
réplique que j'ai entendue depuis
longtemps pour voir un peu quand on
regarde un homme quand on veut le
connaître mieux regarder sa femme aussi
regarder sa femme parce qu'elle est
belle donc pourquoi pas donc maintenant
enfin je veux dire c'est pas grave mais
tu avoues qui aime bien les femmes quoi
j'aime bien les êtres ouais mais je
crois qu'il faut pas se cacher il faut
pas avoir de tabou il faudra il faut
vivre ça avec le sourire moi les gens
m'attire il ya des hommes que je trouve
intéressant il ya des mots que je trouve
intéressante mais aucune frontière dans
ma vie dans ma sensualité un nez dans
mes amours certaines personnes assument
leurs fantasmes et d'autres pas oui moi
je fais partie des gens
c'était assumé ça évite l'aigreur tu as
l'air de bien se faire du bien oui c'est
bien oui tu as pris conscience à quel
âge que tu es mais aussi les femmes mais
tout petit mois ah bon oui j'avais le
carrelage fait trois ans quatre ans
avant tout petit je veux rester comme ça
j'étais fasciné par les gens et au début
ça t'a culpabiliser tu disais non mythe
du tout même si l'outil tu t'es jamais
dit tu t'es jamais dit c'est bizarre je
suis attiré par les femmes non non parce
que j'ai toujours aimé ce qui était un
peu interdit
ouais c'était le côté mêle aventure
et aujourd'hui alors je veux dire que tu
fréquentes des hommes des femmes ou
seulement des femmes
il est vrai qu'il ya des gens qui je
fais la cour et d'autres qui je fais
jardin ça dépend des fois en forêt la
cour jardin - un haut la cour la cour
est alors je sens dans tout ça qu'est-ce
qu'elle commet elle vivait sa george
sand année bonjour je c'en est une
principalement une femme à homme c'était
une femme qui aimait les hommes toute sa
vie et qui a eu quelques attirance pour
une marie dorval par exemple était une
comédienne qui était un petit peu ce
qu'ils veulent adjani d'époque mari
quelques femmes comme ça dans sa vie
mais je crois que c'était
elle a vécu ses attirances et ses amours
le plus honnêtement possible son femme
très honnête qui a vécu sa vie affective
sa vie sa vie d'écrivain je trouve c'est
un exemple pour moi
alors imagine qu aujourd'hui une jeune
fille car garde cette émission et qu'ils
soient qu'ils jeunes qui s'est passé
dans un milieu un peu style à tout ça et
qu'ils soient tentés par par les femmes
tu dirais quoi
non il faut vivre les expériences qu'on
a envie de vivre il faut surtout vivre
les choses avec le choeur avec le cul si
je peux me permettre
l'égarement et pour être sûr de ne rien
rater de nos latitudes abonnez vous y
mettez un peu de bleu